La ciudad más cosmopolita, la mejor gastronomía, el peso de la cultura, todo eso y mucho más
es… Londres.
En un pasado vídeo, por supuesto aquí en
VisualPolitik,
Fonseca ya nos contó cómo
está megapolis ha logrado convertirse en
una de las ciudades que más crecen del mundo.
que ha hecho que la capital
británica esté hoy luchando con la mismísima
Nueva York por conquistar el título que la
reconozca como la Capital mundial de las finanzas,
la capital del dinero.
-"Londres es otro mundo. De hecho a día de hoy ya es la cuarta capital que más rápido está creciendo.
Casi al mismo nivel que Dubai".
En ese vídeo, Fonseca nos habló mucho de
inmigración, de servicios profesionales y,
sobre todo, de La City, que viene a ser algo
así como otra ciudad, un territorio autónomo
hecho por y para las finanzas, en pleno corazón
de Londres. Su estatus es tan particular que,
como vimos, cuenta incluso con sus propias
leyes, su propia policía y sus propios gobernantes.
Podríamos decir que la City es algo así
como una especie de Vaticano donde la fe es,
en este caso, el dinero y los cardenales son
los grandes bancos.
Sin embargo, en 2016 se produjo, estoy convencido
que lo recordáis bien, un acontecimiento
que hizo temblar, literalmente, los cimientos
de este modelo: el 23 de junio de dicho año,
los ciudadanos del Reino Unido votaron a favor
de abandonar la Unión Europea, votaron a
favor
del Brexit.
Así que, nos falta una pregunta fundamental:
¿Será capaz de sobrevivir la City al Brexit?
Y eso es, precisamente lo que vamos a tratar
de responder en este vídeo.
Pero, antes que nada:
A La City se la conoce también como Square
Mile, la milla cuadrada, porque esto es, precisamente,
lo que mide su superficie.
Sí, es un poquito más grande que el Vaticano,
pero muchísima más pequeña que
La Gran Manzana: Manhattan es 20 veces más grande.
Vamos, que en media hora nos podemos recorrer
la City de punta a punta por el largo, y también
por el ancho.
A pesar de ellos, no os equivoquéis, porque
la City no es un juego de niños.
De hecho, es por volumen de transacciones, el mayor centro financiero
del mundo, que se dice pronto.
Para que os hagáis una idea, en este minúsculo
espacio viven tan solo 9.000 personas pero
cada día van a trabajar más de 300.000
y están presentes 250 bancos internacionales.
Pero ¿queréis dos datos capaces de poneros
los pelos de punta?
Pues atentos:
En La City se negocian cada día productos
financieros por valor de casi dos billones
de dólares ¡la tercera parte del total que
se mueve en todo el mundo!
En está ciudad se gestiona, atentos, el 40%
de todas las operaciones en euros y también
el 40% de todo el mercado mundial de divisas
¡Es, impresionante!
Y claro, todo este enorme negocio supone
miles de millones en comisiones y… también
en impuestos.
La City, hoy por hoy, es una auténtica mina
de oro para el gobierno del Reino Unido: cada
año le genera al gobierno británico más
de 80.000 millones de dólares.
Y, amigos, el dinero llama dinero, así que
ahora podemos entender porque Londres, a pesar
de su agradable clima, es
una de las ciudades con más millonarios del mundo.
Aquí es fácil encontrar a oligarcas rusos,
jeques del petróleo, miembros de la realeza europea...
vamos, millonarios de todos los
tipos y colores.
Visto todo esto es fácil comprender porque
con el Brexit han saltado todas las alarmas
¿Por qué?
Veámoslo.
Pertenecer a la Unión Europea, desde luego,
tiene muchas ventajas.
Una de ellas, muy importante, es el llamado
pasaporte financiero.
Con él los bancos que están en Londres pueden
realizar operaciones en cualquier país de
la Unión Europea sin tener que sacar licencias
locales en cada uno de los países.
Es decir, si un banco internacional se instala
en Londres puede operar en toda la Unión
Europea y, además, sus trabajadores pueden
ir y venir sin necesitar ninguna documentación.
Por ello, cuando un banco extranjero quiere
hacer negocios en Europa se establecen en
La City, donde además se beneficia de todas
las ventajas de esta ciudad.
Y, ojo, porque no solo hablamos de menos regulaciones
o menos impuestos, también de la capacidad
de hacer muchos más negocios gracias al peso
que Londres tiene en las finanzas internacionales.
Esto es lo que explica que Londres, a pesar
de utilizar la Libra Esterlina, sea la capital
del euro.
Y claro, es evidente, si Reino Unido abandona
la Unión Europea desaparecerán los más
de 330.000 pasaportes financieros que esta
ciudad tiene registrados.
En ese caso, todos los grandes bancos internacionales
que quisieran tendrían que abrir filiales
en alguno de los otros países de la Unión
Europea con todos los costes que ello implica.
- "Puede ser Dublín, puede ser Frankfurt, puede ser Paris y puede ser Madrid".
Por ello, algunos de los bancos más grandes
del mundo, como Goldman Sachs, JP Morgan
o Bank of America se opusieron al Brexit.
Y también por esto en los últimos tiempos
están apareciendo noticias como estas:
Así que, si nos preguntan, casi podríamos
contestar que hay que ser muy atrevidos para
poner en juego está ruleta de la fortuna
¿No os parece?
Bueno, pues… la verdad… no todo está
tan claro, hay mucho que decir al respecto
y desde luego el futuro no está para nada
resuelto.
De hecho, los mismos pronósticos se hicieron
cuando Reino Unido decidió pasar del euro
y quedarse con la libra.
Veamos que ocurrió.
Cuando Reino Unido decidió quedarse fuera
del euro, prácticamente los mismos bancos
y también muchos expertos dijeron que la
cosa estaba clara: la moneda común suponía
el final para La City, no había nada que
hacer, la suerte estaba echada.
Paris, Madrid, Milán y sobre todo Frankfurt,
la ciudad del poderoso Banco Central Europeo,
serían, sin lugar a dudas, las nuevas capitales
financieras de Europa.
Pero lo cierto, es que se equivocaron un poquito.
Bueno, a decir verdad, se equivocaron tanto
que ocurrió todo lo contrario:
Desde que apareció el euro no solo la economía
del Reino Unido ha crecido más que la de
la eurozona, sino que La City ha incrementado
muchísimo su tamaño y por supuesto su diferencia
respecto a las ciudades que antes he mencionado.
Sólo un dato: Hoy La City emplea a un 50%
más de personas que en 1999.
No está mal ¿Verdad?
Pero es que, es más, ni una solo de las tres
ciudades europeas con el sector financiero
más importante, está en un país de la Unión
Europea.
Hablamos de Londres, claro está, y Zurich
y Ginebra en Suiza.
Frankfurt es la cuarta!
Y para ser justos, no todo el crecimiento
de La City ha sido gracias a las operaciones
en la Unión Europea.
Atentos al siguiente gráfico, en el vemos
cómo ha evolucionado en el negocio internacional
del Reino Unido dentro y fuera de la Unión Europea:
Vamos, que la Unión Europea cada vez es menos
importante para el Reino Unido y para la City.
Llegados a este punto, puede que las cosas
ya no nos parezcan tan obvias ¿Verdad?
Pues bien, ahora nos queda ver, como puede
explotar La City el Brexit para no solo sobrevivir,
sino incluso, quien sabe, poder seguir creciendo.
El pasaporte financiero es importante, pero
no tanto como se cuenta.
Al fin y al cabo, un banco puede seguir dirigiendo
sus operaciones desde la City y abrir una
filial en cualquier país de la Unión Europea
para seguir operando con el pasaporte a través
de ella.
Además, veremos si finalmente lo pierden.
Es verdad que la UE parece dispuesta a imponerle
al Reino Unido un coste de salida elevado
para dar miedo y prevenir que otros países
sigan el mismo camino.
Pero, amigos, las negociaciones para el Brexit
acaban de empezar y desde luego los británicos
tienen armas suficientes para presionar por
un buen acuerdo ¿Por ejemplo?
500.000 millones de comercio anual con un
balance muy favorable para el resto de la
Unión.
Pero, aun con todo, hay algo mucho más importante:
lo que podamos llamar el soft power financiero,
es decir toda la cantidad de servicios profesionales
que están concentrados en una ciudad financiera,
el tamaño del propio mercado, la regulación
existente, e incluso cosas como el idioma,
las oficinas disponibles o los propios colegios.
Y aquí, Londres arrasa.
- "Los grandes despachos de abogados, las grandes firmas de valoración de empresas".
Y, claro, como muchos partidarios del Brexit
defienden, si La City no tuviese que cumplir
las normas de la Unión Europea podría desarrollar
un marco fiscal y regulatorio aún mucho más
atractivo para el sector financiero, que compensaría
y con creces el tema del pasaporte.
Es verdad, no está claro que lo vayan a hacer,
y desde luego los riesgos son muchos.
Pero sorprendentemente si algo parecen tener
claro en La City es que New York, Singapur
o Hong Kong son adversarios más temibles,
entre otras cosas porque están en las zonas
del mundo que más crecen.
Así que, amigos, todos aquellos que han empezado
la carrera por repartirse las joyas de la
corona puede que se lleven un chasco.
- "Yo no tengo ninguna duda, señoría, de que Madrid es la mejor alternativa para todas esas empresas.
Y por eso, precisamente, el nombre de nuestra candidatura es "Piensen en Madrid".
Bueno  y ¿qué piensas tu? ¿Crees que podrá sobrevivir
La City fuera de la Unión Europea?
¿Crees que ciudades como Madrid podrán arrebatarle el
negocio al todopoderoso corazón de Londres?
Espero vuestros comentarios y no os olvidéis
de darle a Like si este vídeo os ha resultado
interesante y queréis que sigamos hablando
de finanzas.
Un saludoy hasta la próxima.